So what is a medium fidelity prototype?
And how does it differ
from a paper prototype,
like the one you've been working with?
The main difference that is relevant for
us at the moment, is the idea of
interactivity and clickability.
When we worked with the paper prototype,
we had to indicate to users
what happened when they
clicked a given button, and
we had to be able to guide them when
they were confused by our layout.
For our next iteration,
we'll be building a clickable
interactive prototype.
That means, that we could hand a user
the prototype, ask them to do a task and
then get out of the way.
When they click on the screen,
the app will move to the right place.
When they reach their destination,
it should be clear.
It's important to remember, that this
doesn't mean that we have a beautiful or
well designed prototype yet.
We don't have animations.
We don't have perfect lines set up.
And we don't have a final look for
the app.
In fact, for our medium fidelity
prototype, it's possible to simply take
your paper prototype, draw it in
marker on a piece of paper, and
import it into a prototyping software.
The key here is having primary
navigation points, which enable you to
get feedback on whether a user can
achieve your intended task of the app.